hello everybody my name is markiplier
and this is Tyler here hello yeah you
may remember Tyler he was just in LA
visiting me with Wade we had a ton of
fun we recorded a bunch of videos and
I'm actually back in Cincinnati right
now visiting friends and family and of
course Tyler is one of those which oddly
enough I've known Tyler for way longer
than a lot of my friends what was a
fourth grade fifth grade I went by
second grade oh yeah that was it yeah
way way way long ago so we've known each
other forever and you may know him from
the videos that we've done of course we
did the spore series and of course we
did the whisper challenge which is one
of my favorite videos I've ever done on
my channel one of the funniest if you
haven't seen that it's in the
description or watch again if you want
to but when you may not know about Tyler
here is he has a master's degree in
sports administration and why bring that
up and why you guys are huge because we
need your help he has been trying very
hard to get a job in his field but he
has not been able to so he's going to
give you some information about what he
does first so I started college I went
to Wellington College got my Bachelors
of Science and sport admits Sport
Management focus and administration then
I ended up graduating from there
semester early I went to United dairy
farmers and was a first assistant
manager where anytime a store manager
wasn't there I was completely in charge
I assisted in hiring did marketing
signage Sales inventory employee
management all of that stuff during that
time I also started another job with
moose water polo club as an assistant
coach so I spent a lot of time with them
coaching as well as helping with
administrative stuff like event planning
event management operations then I left
both of those places because I still
going to find a job my field went to
grad school at the University of
Northern Colorado where I got my masters
in sport administration and since
graduated went and started an internship
after pro camps where I was a marketing
intern was highly successful raised all
my camp's sales by 15% and accounted for
over 20 thousand dollars in revenue
through marketing personal sales through
cold calls customer service and created
a bunch of new marketing initiative
and pants as well yeah that's all that's
all great and this may not make sense to
you because obviously what is this
relevant to you you watch this game
channel 4 gaming videos but he is one of
my oldest friends and the fact that he
has not been able to get a job and he's
one of the hardest-working guys I know
especially considering all the things
he's been through in his life he's one
of the nicest most caring guys everyone
that meets this guy loves him to death
and the reason we're telling you guys
this is because you can help us there's
going to be about a million or so people
that watch this video and I know for a
fact that one of you out there knows
someone or has a friend or a family
friend or a parent or anyone involved in
their life that knows someone that is in
a position to hire someone and he is an
excellent excellent worker and you can't
just take my word for it he has a
LinkedIn profile down in the description
below so if you want to help out and we
could really use your help and I know
this is not the usual videos that we do
here but because we're all a huge
community and I want to know that I can
be there for my friends when they need
it the most
like he currently you're working at
Dick's Sporting Goods right now which is
not anywhere near his field it's gonna
say like a high school summer job yeah
it's like a high school summer job he's
working at because he can't find a job
in his field so if there's someone
anyone out there that knows anyone that
is willing to even look at his resume
please look down the description below
this is LinkedIn profile you can find
all the necessary information down there
either share this video so you can get
words from his mouth of what he's done
how good of a worker he is he has
references he owes all sorts of things
we can all be there for each other and
there's a dog barking over there this is
all that's Ruby that's Ruby the stylish
doggies bargain over there barking up a
storm but I just want to know that you
guys can be there when we need you the
most and in small ways we can help
change someone's life because if he can
get a job in his dream field I know
that's what Tyler he's that's all he's
ever wanted was to work in a field
related sports Oh tell him like what
positions you were looking for anyway um
I was looking for something marketing
anything in intercollegiate athletics
absolutely passionate about
intercollegiate athletics and amateur
sport
but I'm also really interested in
professional sport and
Parks and Recreation as well yeah we
might go out drinking tonight not that
he drinks a lot of parties we don't he
actually can't drink that much
cut that part out I got going nope it's
not going out just started back up here
ight wait okay we're back now a meteor
came by hit the camera it was craziest
thing anyway we seem like it's got tired
yeah exactly
we volunteer every other weekend he's
such a good guy this guy here uh so
we're gonna go out we're gonna hang out
tonight we may go to an arcade and play
some air hockey so you never know but uh
thanks again everybody so much for
watching thanks for taking the time and
I'll be back in Cincinnati by the time
you see this or I'll be back in LA by
the time you see this making videos so
five nights at Freddy's 2020 mode is
coming very soon hey lastwords uh thank
you guys um thank you Mark for doing
this no still blown away but yeah my
linkedin's down below yeah thanks for
all to help if this can lead to anything
that's all that matters so thanks again
everybody and as always we'll see you in
the next video bye-bye see ya hey guys
I'm actually editing the video that
you're watching right now I just wanted
to add a little more because you guys
didn't see what happened after the
cameras got turned off
Tyler is obviously one of my very oldest
friends and it's a shame that he's not
able to do what he wants to especially
in his field and after the camera got
turned off he you know he went off to me
obviously because I was there and he
said he was blown away by the fact that
I was trying to help him then I was like
of course I'm gonna help you it's no big
deal like I'd be happy to help you
because I'm very lucky that I get to do
what I want to do and I get to do what I
enjoy doing and I get to do it for a
living and not many people get to say
that and Tyler has always been an early
supporter of what I do in my youtube
channel and what I'm doing here and like
the charity efforts he did for the you
know livestream way back when and come
to LA for the make-a-wish Foundation
charity and it's there's no one I know
that's a harder worker than Tyler so if
there's someone that deserves to get the
position
he wants to work in it is Tyler and you
know he was a little choked up when he
said that he was blown away and then I
got a little choked I'm like dude no
let's just this is put it there it's
okay it's gonna be fine let's just move
on but in the end it's like it's you
guys that can actually help and I know
that it you know it seems selfish of me
to ask especially for just one of my
friends to help him out but in this act
if someone knows someone that can
connect him with someone they can even
give him an interview like that would
change his life because he's been
looking for about a year now for a job
in his field and he has not been able to
get it so if we can get him into that
you know job that would really really
change his life for the better and he
would be so happy I know for a fact that
he would be happy because you know he he
he works very hard and his job where he
is now and he works hard and every job
he's ever done but you know that doesn't
mean he's fulfilled
you know after going for school for so
long for his master's degree and so if
one of you guys can help out please
please do there's a LinkedIn profile
down the description below all the
information is there if you don't know
what to do with it show to a parent a
friend a family friend anyone that you
think might be able to help him out in
what he wants to do and how he wants to
do it so thank you guys so much for
watching thank you so much for
supporting this thank you so much for
supporting me I am actually on the way
into the hospital right now not for me
mind you I'm perfectly healthy I'm not
going to the hospital for me one of my
friends is just getting out of surgery
actually I think they just got out of
surgery
so I'm gonna head down there show him a
little support it was a minor knee
surgery so they should have been in and
on shouldn't be too bad but I'll go give
them a little support so thank you
everybody so much for watching only one
video for a day but tomorrow I will be
back in LA and it's like eight in the
morning right now so tomorrow morning
I'll be back in LA and I'll be working
on 20-20-20 mode for five nights at
freddys for very soon it'll be cool
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you for taking the time to support
this
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye bye